(applause)
- You're a part of our
very exclusive club.
It's very annoying to other people,
but we just don't seem to age, Mario.
(Mario Laughing)
- You're very sweet.
- No, I am, but you aren't.
What's in the water?
Like what are you?
- No you know, I don't know,
I just, that you're very nice, by the way.
I've got really oily skin,
I'm like, if you took a
piece of fried chicken
and just wiped it on my face.
- [Kelly] Look you're the same.
You're the same.
- Oh my gosh. I don't even--
- Hashtag! We should start a
hashtag we can't stand you.
- Oh, that's funny.
- It's not fair, it's crazy.
- Oh my gosh.
When was that?
Oh, that's 2000.
Oh wow.
Wow, that's almost 20 years ago.
Oh my God,
- [Kelly] Don't brag.
Now it's bragging!
- I didn't realize it.
- I mean you could pull
up a picture from Idol
and it's, well it's real different, Mario.
- I was there.
I saw you a couple times.
I remember, I was there when
you did, it's funny cause
I remember I was in the
audience, you did "Walk On By".
It was Burt Bacharach night.
- I did!
- You killed it too.
- He was kind of a little upset
cause I was supposed to do
"Anyone Who Had a Heart".
And then at the last minute
we were just so tired.
And my voice was so tired.
- You killed that.
I loved that one, yes.
- I gotta do this other one, but I love it
cause Aretha had done it
and I love Aretha.
You remembered that!
- I just remembered I was in
the audience for that.
Fun fact.
- Well now, okay, you're
hosting Access now,
and you've transitioned from Extra.
So what's that like?
- Yeah, I'm so excited to
be part of the NBC family.
And yeah we've got Access Hollywood,
Access Daily and All Access.
And what's cool about it is
we're the only show that goes live.
So we're giving you the latest up
to the minute headlines.
Whatever's going on in the
world of entertainment.
Literally as it's happening.
Going live all over.
There's such an energy to that
and it's obviously incredibly topical.
But it's a great team over there
and we're having a lot of fun.
And then--
- It's hard to be live all the time.
- Yeah it's fun.
And then you know when
you're getting done though.
You know when you're getting done.
But then during the day too
it's cool cause we focus on,
I always say civilians, like real people.
Human interest stories.
Sorta like what People
magazine was back in the day.
And what's important to a lot of moms
out there and families.
I mean, I got three kids.
My other co-host has three kids as well.
And I know you got four. And
so, balancing life and work.
So I'm just, I feel very blessed.
And having a great time doing it.
- It is a balance though, when
you have all those kiddos,
and you're married.
- It really is.
And the kids have, my
kids, their activities,
their schedules are busier than mine.
- I know.
- You know what I mean.
It's crazy
- And I like to keep them busy
cause I don't want them to get in trouble.
- That was my mom's philosophy with me.
She put me in, that's why
I was the only dancing,
karate, wrestler, theater kid I knew.
Every day.
Cause growing up in Chula Vista
wasn't exactly the most
upscale neighborhood.
There was a lot potential
to get in trouble.
So she kept me busy.
I didn't have time to get trouble.
- I feel like everything you
say about yourself just makes
you cooler than all of us.
Every time you open your mouth.
I'm like wait, what.
I was like, you took dance?
That must have been a
cool thing for chicks.
They were like, "Oh hey he dances".
- To be honest I got teased a lot.
Cause I was usually the only boy.
So yeah thank God--
- That's why my husband
became a cheerleader.
So he could be the only guy.
He was like, "I'll lift you up".
- That's funny.
But that's why I was also wrestling and
doing everything else too.
But I didn't want to quit
because you know, it cost money.
And for my mom, I didn't
want to disappoint my mom.
And let her down.
And then I'm glad I didn't
cause then I found out
that women like guys
that know how to move.
- Exactly, we all did.
- So it worked out (laughs)
- So how is your brand new
baby? You have a brand new baby.
You have two older ones.
- Yes I have Gia, and
Dominic, and Santino.
Yeah he's like brand new.
He's so chill.
He's my most chilled out baby, so far.
- [Kelly] So far.
- That's the first day
of school right there.
So the two kids, Gia
and Dominic, are going
to the same school.
I love that they get to wear uniforms too.
Isn't that the best?
- Me too.
- Mine just started school.
Cause it's hell deciding
on, cause with a girl--
- And then you don't have to worry about
keeping up with the Joneses and stuff.
It's just like that's what
you're wearing and that's that.
- Wait, my daughter doesn't do that.
She's just like Punky Brewster.
She likes to put everything on
and it's all mismatched.
And my nanny wants to kill herself.
Yeah, I'm fine with it.
- It's one less thing to worry about.
- But my nanny is always like, "Oh My God,
I have to walk in with that".
- Right, exactly.
- You know, but I love that.
That's so awesome. But
you posted a video telling
your older kids that they
were getting a baby brother.
Let's see it.
- [Mario] You ready to find
out what you're having?
- Yes, yes, I'm so scared.
- You're having--
- Just tell us!
- [Mario] A little brother!
(squeals)
- Having a boy.
Yes, I'm the queen.
- [Mario] You're the queen.
You can still protect her,
you can still protect your little brother.
- Yes, I'm the queen.
(audience clapping)
What she got from that
is, I have no competition.
That's what she got.
- Exactly, no one's going
to be borrowing her clothes.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- You know we waited on
all three of the kids
to find out what we were having.
It took some convincing
initially with my wife.
But then she loved it.
You're excited. It's either a boy or girl.
It's not like, "oh, it's a monkey".
It's not a real big surprise.
- It's a fifty-fifty.
- You still get a euphoric feeling.
And we didn't tell the kids either
until we got home from the hospital.
So that's when I recorded them.
It was fun.
- Oh my gosh that's sweet.
- Anybody pregnant out there it's awesome
to wait by the way.
Its awesome to wait.
- Anyone pregnant out
there I'm just sorry,
I mean I'm happy for you, but I'm sorry.
You probably feel horrible it's great.
They're great when they
come out you'll love it.
Are Gia and Nico helping
out with the new baby?
- Yeah, they're obsessed
with the baby right now.
And Gia, she's only 8, but she's
such a great little helper.
It's like I have a little
nanny that I don't have to pay.
It's great.
She'll feed him, she'll take care.
And then my son Dominic can't wait
to start taking him to
wrestling, jiu jitsu.
If it was up to me I'd keep having them.
My wife says, hey you can
keep having them, but--
But I love it. I like the
chaos, you know we have the dog,
the kids, everybody running around.
So I like it.
- I like a big family too.
I think cause I grew
up not with my family.
I was only really with my mom.
So it's like I didn't
grow up around my brothers
and sisters and that's
why I love it so much
right now with ours.
And I want more.
And my husband is like, "No".
Cause we have four.
But you're kids are also
on your radio show too.
You involve them at work right?
- Yeah, well I do the show
with my wife actually.
"On With Mario", by the way,
if you're interested in checking it out.
Its cool.
I love working with her.
She only comes a couple days a week
and we bank the segments.
She'd probably kill me if I had
to sit everyday right there.
But it's fun we got the
whole family in on the act.
The kids, oh she's interviewing
I think Adam Levine
in that particular clip right there.
She loves Maroon 5.
But my kids also do movie reviews.
And if they're rated R then
they just watch the trailer.
Then they do unseen movie reviews.
It's pretty funny.
- I wanna see them do
movie reviews of rated R.
- But Gias has done red
carpets, interviewed everyone
from The Rock to Ellen, to everyone.
- What? Okay.
That's amazing.
So Gia also has...
I love Gia.
Gia also has a side hustle I'm aware of.
She sells her drawings.
- She's a little entrepreneur.
She likes to sell her little artwork.
And she negotiates everything.
And so we're running a
studio one day or something.
- Well there is one piece of
artwork that I really, really
love that I want to get to.
The tooth fairy thing I saw,
I think it was on Instagram.
This letter is magical and
I want us to put it up.
"Dear Tooth Fairy,
Over the years you have given me money
because I have given you my teeth.
This year I would kindly ask
you if I could keep my teeth.
Please circle Yes or No."
And then she hearts Yes.
And then she says, "thank
you for your generosity
over the past years".
She is very polite.
- Very polite.
- I love her.
- I always say manners are so important.
I teach my kids the most important words
are please, thank you, you're
welcome, and excuse me.
- That's very Southern as well.
- So I won't answer them unless they start
with that sentence.
But yeah, she was trying
to basically hit her up
for more money.